this is honestly not click bait I can't
think of a worst show that I've seen
that has some form of tangible
production value putting aside all of
the major changes that the writers made
to the IP of Scooby-Doo this show is
still absolutely horrendous at a
fundamental Baseline this show has some
of the worst writing I have ever
witnessed the dialogue is molded from
Pure cringe as almost every line is
infected with pop culture references as
if this is Deadpool have you ever
noticed how pilot episodes of TV shows
always have more gratuitous sex and
nudity than the rest of the series oh my
God I have the jokes are wholly unfunny
and are at times very jarring like this
line that made me do a double take you
didn't mention Fred had a tiny dong oh
yeah real baby carrot and I'm gonna ride
it all the way to Victory
just from two episodes alone there are
so many crazily baffling moments that
not even David and Dan could come up
with in season 8 of Game of Thrones I
wish I was making this up but there's a
scene where velma's Dad's girlfriend
takes off her clothes and starts posing
for pictures while her unborn baby
protrudes through her skin
I don't know what the hell is happening
and if the writers think this is
supposed to be funny then they're high
now the even crazier thing is that this
is just scratching the surface there's
so many other insane moments like let's
go through some examples Fred gets shot
in his legs by the police and as they're
dragging him out to the cop car his
clothes fall off and everyone can see
his penis unrelated to that he also cuts
off some random kids leg in school
Shaggy or sorry I mean Norville now
tries to sell one of his kidneys so that
he could have enough money to impress
Velma and even Velma tries to sell drugs
to her own father this show is batshit
crazy and I have no idea why anyone
would approve of these scripts I refuse
to believe that any higher upset HBO
actually read these scripts because
there is no way they would green light
this just talking about some of these
scenes feels like I'm attending a
support group as I reflect on this
traumatizing experience Velma is
classified as a quote-unquote comedy but
at no point does any potential joke work
firstly the show is so obsessed with
wanting to be meta so much to the point
that it compromises any character as
seeming real I'm a
im as we're good at solving
one positive stereotype perpetuated by
cop shows and instead it just comes
across as the writers wanting to make
random jokes that don't fall in line
with other characters would
realistically say the show immediately
cements itself within this kind of
dialogue so the audience is right away
getting annoyed by the humor and since
there is no humor there also isn't any
form of good Drama characters or
dialogue to fall back on along with this
being accompanied by the most bizarre
scenes I've ever seen another aspect of
the comedy within this show is that it's
immature humor despite this supposedly
being a more adult and mature rendition
of Scooby-Doo to name a few examples
there are parents stabbing random sex
jokes or repeating the same joke over
and over there's also random escalations
that don't make any sense in the moment
that will leave the audience confused
instead of laughing the show never
really establishes a clear internal
logic and you are constantly getting
torno Whiplash at times the show can be
somewhat normal and then we are
transported into such weird scenarios
then another important aspect of comedy
is that you want it to be subtle and to
have the audience to understand it
without explaining the joke generally
this is done through Visual gags but
even as this example shows the writers
instantly ruin the joke by having some
random person Shout It Out Loud for the
audience oh God he looks like Hitler and
not just because we compare everyone to
Hitler these days then lastly in regards
to the humor there's just so many almost
objectively unfunny moments now I should
use the word subjectively because it's a
comedy but I don't know who would find
some of this funny as an example that
includes a setup and a punch line Velma
goes to check out what's on her dad's
girlfriend's camera now the
possibilities could be endless for this
joke but Velma finds out that she takes
pictures of babies and vegetables to
make money like okay I'm sure you could
have had a way better punchline for that
joke but that wasn't the case and it was
just some random stupid thing then
somehow the writers have made each
character from Scooby-Doo immensely
unlikable to the point that this feels
like some weird parody you would find on
YouTube at 1am Velma is unbearably
annoying as she's always being snarky
arrogant overly confident and in general
very disrespectful to everyone around
her let alone almost all of her dialogue
being meta humor I spit truth without a
filter like every comedian before
hashtag me too look Fred is a rich
douchebag who is borderline psychotic
and is also a literal baby in the show
my name is Fred there's a scene where he
is given the task of cutting a steak and
he doesn't know what to do Daphne is now
a drug dealer according to TV it's
morally okay to deal drugs if your life
is just kinda crappy and norvel is
really the only somewhat normal person
in comparison to everyone but he's still
very annoying didn't answer my the ends
voicemails because I still don't know if
you listen to my VMS voicemails though I
left you some other VMS voice I know
what VMS are these foreign people do not
resemble anyone from Scooby-Doo in any
manner they feel like stark contrast as
to who they should be if you were to
remove their names and slightly change
their visual designs no one would be
able to guess who these characters were
supposed to be who they are none of them
are likable and they are truly
despicable the worst of the bunch to me
is Fred through the course of episode 2
we learned that Fred is a rich Late
Bloomer and because of this he has the
mentality of a five-year-old spoiled
brats I don't know if the writers are
trying to over exaggerate these issues
for the sake of Comedy or something but
it doesn't even come across as being
funny so what we are left with is an
uncomfortable moment that ruins the
character that we used to love along
with the show overly trashing white men
as being bad and comes across as
tasteless since these are also
pre-existing characters from tons of
past content we're naturally going to
compare them to their original
counterpart words so when the original
characters are on the opposite end of
the Spectrum in comparison to the new
characters then it's going to be jarring
along with a lot of the comedy feeling
like diminishing humor that is flat out
insulting to the characters like if
these characters weren't at all related
to Scooby-Doo then whatever it would
just be a random forgettable and bad
show but the fact that these are
pre-established characters that we are
used to makes this experience even more
Dreadful the show resembles some cursed
parody of Scooby-Doo instead of a more
mature prequel show that it was
advertised as and speaking of a mature
show the writers for some reason
associate adult with excessive and
gratuitous sex and nudity this is not
what people want to see when watching
Scooby-Doo in general and the weird
thing is that the writers are even
self-conscious about this aspect and
make a joke about having sex in the show
to drawn viewers but who in their right
mind would want to watch the show for
that let alone them even advertising
that it comes across as incredibly
childish and completely ruins the humor
when you you're immediately stooping
this low like the first minute of
episode 1 alone would have quickly
deterred me if I wasn't going to make a
video about this show to quickly detail
what happens in that first minute we
have two cockroaches having sex I wish I
could be making that up a joke about how
origin story is being reserved for
powerful white men and for women it's
about hot chicks going crazy another sex
joke with Fred's van and showing a
locker room full of naked girls with a
heavy-handed fourth wall-esque breaking
joke and this minute essentially
highlights everything that is wrong with
the writing from the stupid dialogue of
characters referencing pop culture very
weird and off-putting humor and an
uncomfortable inclusion of nudity
despite censoring it so I guess I can
show this and not get demonetized
hopefully the fact that the show got
worse from this first minute was very
surprising to me if She-Hulk looks like
a great normal show in comparison to
yours then you're doing something wrong
I would make this video longer and go
into a deeper analysis but I fear I
would lose my mind and doing so so thank
you for watching and please do not watch
this show and get away while you still
can